welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture we'll talk about the
higgs mechanism
as you might know the higgs boson was
discovered in 2012
by the lhc experiments um but the
theoretical discovery of the higgs boson
happened
much much earlier than that in the mid
1960s peter hicks
and a few others proposed a mechanism
which gives rise to masses of the gauge
both on the w and the z
boson and the higgs boson or the hex
fields and can only also be used to give
masses to the fermions
so let's have a look at this and start
with
a simple observation um when we have
write down our lagrangian force
simple spin one field gauge field um
like a photon we find that we want to
have
local gauge invariants for this
lagrangian which means that we can do a
local gauge transformation
of our fields and the physics should be
unchanged of this
so the physics meaning the description
by the lag martian should be invariant
under this transformation
all right the problem however is that if
you want to have
a spin one gauge field which is massive
you have to have terms in your like
version
like this one here where
where you have a mass mass term for your
for your fields so in general this is
not possible
um without breaking gauge invariants
and this is a guiding principle of our
for all lagoon theory
so this is a real bummer um so
you know if you want a stopping point so
you have a beautiful theory which
describes
all the interactions but one important
one important
characteristics the masses of the
particle is missing
but you are able to actually do this not
just by
not by adding a specific mass term but
by breaking the symmetry by breaking the
local gauge symmetry
there's various ways to do this and one
of the ways is to
use spontaneous symmetry breaking so
what is spontaneous symmetry breaking
imagine you have
a symmetry rotation symmetry like this
pen here
um and by applying some force on top
this
pen would bend and by bending this pen
it you know bends in one specific
direction
that breaks the rotational symmetry
another way to look at this is to just
let this pen drop
let it go to its ground state lowest
possible energy state
and it will land somewhere on the table
and by doing this breaking the symmetry
and it does this spontaneously
let's look at spontaneous symmetry
breaking in a toy model first
so what we want to do here is just add a
complex scalar field
and the corresponding potential for this
field potential is shown here
and this general potential can have
multiple forms so the first form would
just be this
parabola here this is solution where mu
square
this term with square is greater than
zero in this term
um there's this unique minimum the
minimum is here at zero
and because of that uh the mass of the
sphere
would be equal to zero and the mass of
our gauge field would also be
equal to zero but what happens now
if we have through this potential
uh a breaking of the symmetry so in this
case here
the vacuum itself the lowest energy
state breaks the symmetry you go away
from the zero point and you
you're breaking this symmetry um
so this minimum is at v
over square root two um v is the vacuum
expectation value
of this field and you can just simply
rewrite then this field itself
by evolving it around its minimum and so
you find
two fields here the sky and this h
again the h is already kind of pointing
towards the higgs boson
and the vacuum expectation value now if
you add this back into your lagrangian
and i'll do this again this is shown
here but also on the next slide
you can start to identify terms which
look like mass terms for your particle
and the first one is here
which can be identified as a mass term
for our gauge field the mass is e times
v
e times v is the strength of
the coupling of this gauge field e times
the
value of the vacuum expectation value
all right
so this is interesting so we used this
this new scalar field um to break
spontaneously this symmetry and then a
mass term appears which is proportional
to the strength of the coupling
and the vacuum expectation value so the
mass is generated
through electro weak through the
spontaneous symmetry breaking
and the coupling to the field you also
find the mass term for the sixth field
here for this
h field this is not the higgs boson it's
just a field which looks like it
and so this mass term is here but
remember that mu square is less than
zero and then this sky or the so-called
volts goldstone boson
its mass is zero but then we have those
terms left over here which we cannot
really interpret it very well
and it's possible to remove them by
the by choosing a specific field
so we do a gauge transformation by just
re
relabeling things and then the new
lagrangian is independent of this field
just as a reminder goldstone the gold
spawn
goldstone boson you find those goldstone
bosons in many places in physics
and jeffrey goldstone is a retired
faculty at mit so you might
in the spring or next summer you find
them walking across the corridors
um so we find our new lagrangian which
you know has our mass terms here
which has the term for the higgs field
and has our potential for the higgs
field
so this specific gauge we just decided
to use is the
so-called unitarity gauge um and it's
important to note that
the lagrangian itself contains all
physical part
particles but the sky this goldstein
golden is gone
and the lingo we sometimes use here as
the goldstone boudon has been eaten
by the physical bosons and the way it
has been eaten
is through uh the longitudinal
polarization of those both under that
equivalent of saying that
it has acquired mass so the pocket guide
here
for symmetry for spontaneous symmetry
breaking is such that
um in some spontaneous symmetry breaking
of a u1 gauge symmetry
by a non-zero vacuum expectation value
of a
complex scalar field results in a
massive gauge boson
and one real massive scalar field so we
created mass
but as a side product we also have an
additional field
and that field itself has a mass term so
it's massive
the second scalar field we had just
disappeared the ghost and boson
has been eaten by the longitudinal
component
of the gauge field itself
all right that was a simplified toy
model
let's look at the standard model so now
here we have to generalize
from u1 to su-2 or s-u-n h-groups the
scala field is now an n-dimensional
fundamental
representation of that group for the
standard model that would be
su2 um the gauge fields
are n square minus one dimensional joint
representations
now for like our photon for example or
our
unmixed w uh bottom field
and the lagrangian looks very similar to
the one we just
before with our potential again we have
this mu square term we also have a
lambda term here
and then we require a local gauge
invariance again
okay so now for the standard model again
sc2 cross
u1 gauge groups uh we introduce a sky a
complex
field a comp complex six field in su-2
it's a duplet
meaning that it has four components uh
it's it's
complex and has two components which
means there's a total of four components
to it
so we already know that we want to use m
square less than zero
for our potential to allow for
spontaneous symmetry breaking to occur
the minimum is then at
um 1 over square root 2
0 for the upper component and v the
vacuum expectation for the lower
component
that's the choice already
again why musically less than zero
because if that we would have chosen to
use a positive value
positive value for mu square we wouldn't
have spontaneously broken the symmetry
okay so we need to have potential which
looks like this mexican head here
all right so now we can you know what
happens now to our w and z bosons
we have discussed electro weak mixing
already
good so that was the first step now we
understand we'll understand where the
mass terms actually come from
so now we we just did the electro
we did the spontaneous symmetry breaking
and now we're looking at what happens
now if we also couple the higgs field
to the botons so again we write this
this way and then we just try to find
terms it's really like a mechanical
writing of the individual terms
and you find again terms which have a
vacuum expectation value here
and the coupling here and we find the
coupling
um to the u1 term and the the coupling
to the
su-2 and the coupling to the u1 term uh
representative to
the coupling to the original photon
field
and our uh gauge field for seo2
all right the rest is rewriting and
identifying terms
if we do this and this is like a couple
of pages of writing
fine but if we do this we find again
like before that we find the first and
second component
of our gauge sq2 gauge field gives us
the charged
um the charge vector both and the w plus
and the w
minus and then the z bother and the
photon are mixtures
of the third component
and the the field b all right
so this is another or physical fields
and then we may try to identify the mass
terms we find for the w
that the w mass is proportional or equal
to
the coupling in the coupling strength
of the se2 group times the vacuum
expectation value over two
and the mass of the z boson is given by
both couplings times the square root of
the
square root of the square sum of the
squared times v
over two okay if you're trying to look
for mass term for the photon we find
none
meaning that the photon is massless and
then we can
look again at our weak mixing angles and
they are now defined
directly through the couplings in those
two gauge groups
the masses of the w and the z-bosons are
related
via this weak mixing angle cosine theta
w
right those elements we already saw
before
now we find that the masses of the gauge
botans are given by
spontaneous imagery breaking we are the
vacuum expectation value
and the strength of the coupling of the
gauge field
to the hex field
all right so summary we started with a
complex scalar field
a representation of su-2 is 4 degrees of
freedom
the higgs vacuum expectation value
breaks the symmetry spontaneously
the w plus and w minus and the z voltage
acquire mass
and the three goldstone bosons are each
absorbed
into the w's and the z boson we also
find
an additional scalar hex bodon that
remains
and so that was the study the the
understanding in the 60s and 70s and the
standard model was further developed
and then it took us all the way to 2012
to actually find
this new scholar particle export on
itself
you